the Joe Rogan experience I'm going to a
voice doctor right now cuz I don't wanna
ruin not like my instrument and which
I'm now starting to look at it as an
instrument that I was never taught how
to play
I'm just freestyling on this [ __ ]
saxophone you know like no one I've
never gotten less we don't get lessons
for our voice right right have you ever
taken any no it's a good idea though I
mean you talk so much have you ever lost
your do you lose your voice ever no okay
well then you're probably talking the
right way yeah but you probably scream
in a really efficient way or yell in an
efficient way I think you just have
strong vocal chords yeah I mean I'm
learning stuff that I'm like whoa I
didn't even know like there's three
places where your voice can come from
your throat your mouth and your nose and
I'm talking all throat and that's why
I'm getting polyps developing I mean I'm
getting stuff growths on it because I
don't know how to talk and it's just my
vocal cords are slamming all day and
they develop calluses after they slam
and those are like the and I'm gonna
have to have them surgically removed I'm
gonna lose my voice if I don't they're
like you're here right in the nick of
time so I do voice exercises every day
and I'm losing it I start out and go
opening up your throat and it's so your
vibrate and it's making you realize that
the vibrations in your face cause a lot
of your the sound so it's your nose and
your mouth that you can focus on
creating the sound that comes out of
your that makes your the air okay then
you go mmm um and you're supposed to
make your whole face vibrate
right now people screaming they're
[ __ ] hating this and you should
so yeah just in my house going never
Monday number more money just like
London every Monday never Monday that's
still a little throaty yeah yeah
[Applause]